Дозвіл на експлуатацію "Північного потоку-2" треба переглянути.
З відповідною вимогою до суду звернулася німецька екологічна організація
Deutsche Umwelthilfe. Її представники стверджують, що треба
враховувати нові методи вимірювання витоку метану
під час видобутку і транспортування газу, і на основі доступних зараз наукових знань
"Північний потік-2" не отримав би дозволів. За словами екологів,
метан, який є основною складовою природного газу,
завдає у 86 разів більше шкоди клімату, ніж CO2.
Тим часом стало відомо, що судно "Фортуна", яке було одним з кандидатів
на добудову "Північного потоку-2", не братиме участі в будівництві трубопроводу.
Про це повідомила російська компанія МРТС,
у якої в оренді перебуває трубоукладальна баржа.
У червні датський регулятор дозволив Nord Stream 2 під час укладання труб
використовувати судна з якірною системою позиціонування, такі як "Фортуна".
Газопровід "Північний потік-2", який проходить по дну Балтійського моря через територію
Фінляндії, Швеції та Данії, майже добудований. Залишилося прокласти
не більше кількох сотень кілометрів трубопроводу.
На запит DW у Nord Stream 2 заявили, що
"працюють над рішеннями для подальшого укладання трубопроводу".
За відсутності "Фортуни" єдиним спроможним кандидатом залишається
трубоукладач "Академік Черський", який стоїть у німецькому порту Мукран.
"Академік Черський" зможе прокласти кілометри газопроводу, які залишилися,
звісно, набагато повільніше, ніж якби це зробила швейцарська фірма,
але, принаймні, в нього є всі дозволи від урядів Данії та Німеччини,
тож добудувати газопровід "Газпрому" вдасться в будь-якому випадку.
Питання - в подальшій експлуатації цього газогону.
Будівництво "Північного потоку-2" було припинено в грудні 2019 року через американські санкції.
У липні США запровадили нові санкції відносно будь-яких суден,
що беруть участь у прокладанні труб, а також кампаній, які забезпечують
страховку суден і технічне обслуговування. Берлін, як і раніше,
підтримує будівництво трубопроводу і закликає
до деескалації напруженості навколо проєкту.
Підтримує "Північний потік-2" і канцлерка ФРН Анґела Меркель,
яка вбачає в ньому економічний, а не політичний проєкт.
Втім, деякі експерти вважають, що "Північний потік-2" енергетично невигідний Німеччині.
Уряд Німеччини, як і раніше, підтримує "Північний потік-2", хоча, я думаю,
вони хвилюються через збільшення проблем навколо нього і намагаються
переконати американців не допустити жорстких санкцій.
Спіраль санкцій і контрсанкцій закручується і все стає дуже проблематично.
Газопровід "Північний потік-2" за великим рахунком не потрібен Німеччині
з енергетичної точки зору. Він дуже дорогий і, крім того, йде врозріз з цілями захисту клімату.
Але далеко не всі в ЄС підтримують ФРН у цьому питанні.
Нещодавно участь Німеччини у будівництві "Північного потоку-2"
розкритикував прем'єр-міністр Польщі Матеуш Моравецький,
а перед цим управління із захисту конкуренції та прав споживачів Польщі
виписало штраф "Газпрому" на 50 мільйонів євро
через відмову російської компанії надати дані про контракти Nord Stream 2
з європейськими компаніями, які фінансують будівництво газопроводу.
Однак і це ще не все.
У США зараз розмірковують над запровадженням санкцій проти всіх,
хто взяв участь у будівництві газогону, а також щодо покупців газу з цього трубопроводу.
Це було б дійсно серйозною перешкодою,
яку європейські компанії навряд чи зможуть здолати.
За рішенням датського енергетичного агентства Nord Stream 2
може розпочати будівництво газопроводу у водах Данії вже з 3 серпня,
але будівництво поки не відновлено. Всі роботи у територіальних водах Данії
заборонені до кінця вересня через нерест тріски.